sar the one question that we keep
getting asked most often is will we do a
sequel to Finding Nemo
and I am excited and honored to
introduce you the incredible filmmaking
team of finding Dory one of my best
friends the director of wall-e and the
original Finding Nemo Andrew Stanton
co-director Angus macLane and producer
Lindsey Collins so our new film centers
around dory and we couldn't be more
excited to have the great Ellen
DeGeneres back
this is so exciting for me I can't tell
well you do know how exciting it is and
I'm so proud of this film it's so it's I
can't wait for you to say it we should
introduce some of the co-stars alright
alright first up is Inc the octopus he
is voiced by Ed O'Neill star of TV's
Modern Family ladies and gentlemen Ed
O'Neill what are we doing I don't know
that we're supposed to that was you know
we have not we have not worked together
and yet you're hilarious in the film
very very funny and had we worked
together we would have witty banter
about stories and stuff let's make up
stories remember that time yes what do
you hold like oh my god honey
should have been there yeah what do we
do now what are we go so Bailey is
voiced by Ty Burrell also from Modern
Family
and then there is destiny she's a very
sweet but somewhat confused whale shark
who thinks she's a whale even though
she's actually a shark destiny is voiced
by the very funny Palin Olsen from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia
you